real quick pitch Quick Pitch with the
boys imagine AI but it's our wives and
they're just nice to
us I man that'd be such a dream system
[Music]
overload did you guys hear that Sports
Illustrated got busted using AI to post
a bunch of [__] articles
really did it say like chat gbt um I am
not authorized to do this but then you
know like you're supposed to delete the
top part well I don't know if that
happened but um they basically had fake
profile pictures of people editors and
stuff no way fake names and then fake
article well not fake articles but like
AI articles and they like were like
published by Sports Illustrated and they
made it to print made it to print on
their website right and then they they
they got called out for it and then they
took it all down so so what is the issue
that the public has with it why is is it
cuz it's just fake [__] or why did you
put author names if it's AI oh that's
the thing why can't why can't you create
an author using AI you can but you
should tell everybody what you're doing
oh I see oh so they're trying to hide
that it's not AI that's what they did oh
that's lame that's the one of my
favorite sites ever started doing that
and it broke my heart man which one
crack.com
really I mean they would do it though
right yeah it's almost like they're
using AI to read their own articles to
just recycle them really cuz they on a
top 20 list of things three of them will
be the same thing
W it doesn't even know that it's
repeating it's yeah it doesn't even know
they're that lazy but don't people go to
those for opinion pieces like because
they want to know like a position or or
concept from a human I mean you still
have to wonder how they're able to
release six articles per day when no
one's even on that site anymore crazy
maybe nobody reads it yeah it's crazy a
lot of sites are doing that exact same
thing now and you can catch it pretty
easily it's like some zergnet [__] yeah
and look this is sports illustrator
right it's a huge name like this is like
one of the top names in the sports
industry and it's supposed to be one of
the surviving Publications still with
ethics are they surviving that's why I
think maybe why do they have to turn to
AI can't they just have somebody write
these we don't necessarily know like cuz
it could just be a guy who's like trying
to farm a bunch of different numbers and
he started all these accounts so we
don't know it could be the publisher we
don't know like like a data guy do they
still have Bruce Jenner in the bikini
and stuff yeah Bruce Jenner is looking
sexy though yeah Bruce Jenner got cuz
you got a fatter and then like we're
accepting of that now we don't fat shame
here no no no no no we love it about
kayin yeah yeah dude it's there's
there's [__] there's like AI [__]
on my [__] explore page really it's
weird cuz it's like it's like a chick
with like bouncy titties and then her
face is
like doesn't bother me that's just how
she looks it's like what the [__] is
this Grandma's had did that too I don't
give a [__] did you see how some of
these AI uh influencer girls are making
like like hundreds of thousands of
dollars and it's like a guy a girl or
what like a team of people that just
take their faces and turn it into AI how
are they making all that money is it
brand deal cuz people keep buying into
it they're only they make like AI only
fans or whatever no way it's not it's
not even a team it's not even it used to
be a team of people making one now it's
one guy making a team of people say
whatever you want about SS but for some
reason they have a lot of money yeah how
do they spend all this money on these
chip are rich you say whatever you want
about them you go ahead but they are
leers bro they [__] make money dude
that's crazy they're making it but yeah
AI stuff as articles is is different
right it hits different rather than
images like when it's articles and
you're taking time to read it and you
start seeing little weird gages like ho
[__] I just been reading a random
regurgitated thing yeah I I can't I
can't unhear what I just heard about AI
only fans like that
blows well it's a big actually they just
it's not even a human being they busted
some chick who's who making like 15
million or something like that and she's
a complete AI the images AI the videos
Ai and the dialog AI so are they making
them just do like wild crazy [__] or is
it just because it's like some hot [__]
that everybody want see they make them
just like like hey what's up we're
chilling and [__] it's like I remember
there was one she wasn't quite AI but
she was like filtered to Crazy death
right so then her that was in her face
yeah all that but she was making gu like
hella money and I was like it looks too
perfect how do we get into AI only fans
because I feel like that's a victimless
crime there was there was a girl who was
who was you said they got they got
caught or whatever or no this I think
the thing that I that reminded me when
what he just said there was this girl
that would um she would do only fans and
stuff but then she would make her face
look super young like like a kid almost
yeah and then um I I mean she got
exposed tons of times and didn't really
care she was like whatever that's my
character right and then she just like
killed herself randomly Noy Jesus dude
threw that away fallowing yeah always
ends in a death or something that's yeah
her name was like Miss Kitty something I
forgot but you forgot cuz you threw it
away she killed herself yeah she
committed suicide crazy that sucks yeah
that's s she was getting a lot of death
threats people found out she wasn't
really didn't really that reminds me of
that porn star who killed herself cuz
everyone she said she wouldn't do um
scenes with any male performers who had
done gay porn oh yeah yeah yeah and then
she was getting death threat and then
she killed herself what who was that's
crazy I do remember that I don't
remember but yeah I remember that exact
statement yeah and then got dud AI is
super helpful to write professional
emails though cuz like I don't write in
that language and then I'm just like
[__] dude how do I word this and then
like you got to be like um write me this
to the landlord in a professional manner
for this these reasons or whatever right
yeah and tell them I'll suck your dick
if I can avoid rent for 25
days in a professional way thank you so
when you use it so when you use AI in
that type of setting where it's like
you're using it as a tool to help your
business like is the are the ethics
different than a people like making
misleading only fans with AI is like are
those two things the same or different
in your eyes I think it does just come
down to ethics it's like you're not
going to get in trouble for it but if
people don't like it now and they won't
pay further then that's the penalty yeah
you know wow but you don't some of these
AI girls though I'm like you got to be a
dumbass to not know that it's not a real
girl like you really have no contact
with women to think that this cartoon
cuz some of them it's like super smooth
yeah it's like and in the background's
all like perfectly done and I'm like
come on dude you couldn't tell that was
AI some simps so imagine like people
that are down to Jack to [__] Tomb
Raider the video game already this is
already 10 times I'm pretty down in the
'9 this is already 10 times way more
realistic than the Tomb Raider and they
what if they do it knowing it's fake too
yeah they probably don't even give up
that's where I feel like there's a
crossover they thought it was real in
the '90s what no no the AI polygonal
yeah but I think that's the crossover
between Ai and um catfish
victims yeah oh my God you know what I
mean like it's the that's maybe the
biggest growth industry that there is
right yeah yeah yeah you know there's
like people who are being catfish and
you're like how could you think that's a
real person
get demog into
your um entertainment gold mine gold
mine
infinitely crazy cuz the truth never
comes it's sustainable forever yeah you
don't need it cuz you can just say like
oh my God like they fake accidents they
fake all kinds of [__] they use AI
they're like I'm in a hospital bed and
then the guys are like oh she's in a
hospital bed what why are you 5,000 more
dollar right and the AI just writes
narratives writes situations are you
really trying to search if that's real
or not not anymore that is the
reality I think we found our new scheme
here guys but we need a simp angel
investor because they have unlimited
cash unlimited funds we got to learn how
to make [__] AI tech for some reason
they're all Bitcoin billionaires
Financial
Geniuses DCA baby they're just DCA
they're just I guess there's just DCA
it's like unbelievable how low they get
in on this
stuff you guys saw that story with the
dude who was like a a Ruby Rose fan oh
yeah I did I did Ruby Rose is really
popular only fans it was a story that
got out that her top uh like payer
whatever she poses nudes there yeah but
the guy who's like supposedly her top uh
customer they put his like dollar amount
out and I think it's like 67k or some
[__] oh my God and then like they made
him out to be this like crazy ass Super
Fan they put his DMS up it looks really
embarrassing on him and [__] and that he
has like a tattoo with her face and then
it turns out it was all just a marketing
scheme that the dude the dude just like
got paid to like take a photo with her
and be this like scapegoat for this
whole like thing and he's like no I
don't even I don't even like uh pay that
much or anything sure but he says the
the team set the whole thing up with
some input from him that's what he's
claiming but why what it was for good
Mark just to get the word to get more
people
on to get her more popular and it worked
she shared leak um she also shared leak
in an image of her face tattooed on his
body yeah the crazy thing though is that
they made it look one of the most clever
ways that they were able to make it
believable is that they made it look
like he was the same guy from an MTV you
know like the My Strange Addiction or
some [__] one of those shows where he's
like addicted to porn or something and
it looks like that's the same guy but
it's not way so then it makes this
Narrative of like oh yeah he's always
been like that wow but he's like that's
not even me the timeline doesn't even
match well he went viral for being like
her top simp right and like he's
apparently a Bitcoin bro or whatever
apparently yeah and then he like gave
her like 60 G's a month or something 60
I think his his uh yeah it shows his
financial contribution it's like 60
something K but then they say it was
like a big ruse to like get more
attention for her page which makes sense
yeah yeah yeah damn that's crazy cynical
we live in a cruel cynical world we
we're done though dude this is over
we're done dude I think we're just
getting
started cuz it's like technology you
know like the whole scary thing how they
always try to remind you they're like oh
yeah any gripes you have about AI or any
of this stuff it is the worst it's ever
going to be right now [__] well dude but
like the technology when email came out
like your grandparents are like this is
the end of the world yeah so it's like
not really I think we're getting started
cuz the technology improves improves
improves I'm talking about the only
fanship we're done though dude I think
that works hand in hand but also it
depends on what country you live in I
mean but that's why we got to monetize
this real quick pitch Quick Pitch with
the boys imagine AI but it's our wives
and they're just nice to
us I man that'd be such a drink system
overload cannot compute
forgiveness impossible that's funny that
I need a hell of a graphics card for
that one what the hey I'm going to need
a dual I'm going to need a dual graphics
card you know how you I'll be pouring
buckets of ice into that [__] Tower
dude cooling down
dude you know how you're going to be
able to tell if someone's a real girl or
not because AI will always know what
they want to eat see what do you want to
eat I don't know oh you're real you're a
real girl do you think AI is smart
enough to not know so that you think
it's a real girl oh
no nah it just has three dots over and
over forever well she would take a while
she would take a while she's real yeah
she's real take my
[Music]
60k